Black Panther's first cut came in at nearly
two and a half hours which means there are
some intriguing scenes and concepts cut from
the final movie we never got to see.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm going to reveal details about
a deleted Rocky-style montage, footage chopped
from the end of the movie, two characters
Ryan Coogler wanted to include in the film
but couldn't, and much more!
If you're here for the first time, I do regular
Marvel and deleted scenes videos, plus I've
got a Black Panther giveaway running right
now for all my subscribers.
So, make sure you hit the bell and leave me
a comment with your thoughts about the deleted
scenes for a chance to win!
Obviously, spoilers ahead for Black Panther,
so take care if you haven't seen it yet.
Black Panther's crew did an amazing job bringing
the nation of Wakanda to vivid life on screen.
And if writer-director Ryan Coogler had had
his way, we would have seen even more of the
incredible African nation in the final film.
Yes, early drafts of the script included a
scene where T'Challa and Nakia went for a
run through Wakanda to Nakia's home.
Speaking to Digital Spy, Coogler described
the scene as a 'Rocky-style jog', pretty fitting
given the director's second feature film was
Creed.
Although Black Panther had a very healthy
budget, more in fact than several of Marvel's
other recent films, in the end the scene was
cut to save money, though Coogler added that
even if they had shot it he doubts there'd
have been time for it in the final version;
I guess because it wasn't essential to the
actual plot.
If the scene had made it into the movie though,
not only would we have been able to explore
more of the country, but we'd also have met
Nakia's parents and seen what they thought
of T'Challa, their daughter's ex-boyfriend.
Chadwick Boseman revealed there are a couple
of deleted scenes of T'Challa and Everett
Ross in his office.
The scenes he's referring to are likely after
Ross wakes up and talks to Shuri and discovers
that the bullet injury to his spine has been
healed with Wakandan technology.
It's the first time Ross has ever seen Wakanda
and Shuri tells him not to touch anything
as her brother will return soon.
I think there's a snippet of this deleted
scene in the second Black Panther trailer
in the form of a voiceover by Martin Freeman
which could match the discussion he had with
T'Challa in the scene that was cut.
"I have seen gods fly."
"I've seen men build weapons that I couldn't
even imagine."
"I've seen aliens drop from the sky."
"But I have never seen anything like this."
And there's also some footage of Everett Ross
meeting with T'Challa and the Wakandan delegation
at the UN which we never saw in the finished
film.
Judging by Ross's body language in this deleted
clip here, I wonder if he might be trying
to dissuade T'Challa from revealing the truth
about Wakanda, or at least be voicing his
own doubts about what the repercussions might
be?
Either way, the reason this footage is missing
from the theatrical release is that, according
to Ryan Coogler, the ending to the movie was
originally quite different.
Initially, T'Challa's UN speech about opening
up Wakanda to the rest of the world was going
to be the final scene before the credits started
to roll.
In an interview with the Radio Times, Coogler
said, "It was a complicated thing.
[…] It was one of those things where we
were working on the ending in the edit.
[And] we were kind of deciding how we'd play
it.
We knew we had the ability to do a post-credits
sequence if we wanted to."
Coogler also explained that, in the end, he
wanted the final scene to parallel the first
scene in Oakland.
As he said, "If you think about it, the UN
scene, and the scene that happens in Oakland
are basically the same scene.
It's a reveal of who Wakandans are.
The only difference is who they're revealing
that to.
And we thought that it was stronger emotionally
[to end in Oakland]."
Now, what Coogler says does make absolute
sense, though some Marvel fans might have
preferred if the UN speech had been in the
main movie, as we might have got an extra
end-credits scene that way.
And, judging by Everett Ross's body language
in this deleted footage here, I also wonder
if, whether Ross might be trying to dissuade
T'Challa from revealing the truth about Wakanda,
or at least voice his own doubts about what
it might mean?
By the way, if you want to understand why
the ending of Black Panther is so important
for the MCU, plus how it sets up Avengers
Infinity War, then tap up here to watch my
full breakdown of the ending or click the
links in the video description below.
The Kings' all-female bodyguard, the Dora
Milaje play a big part in some of the movie's
most spectacular action sequences, with Danai
Gurira giving an awesome performance as Okoye.
But it looks like there were still some cuts
to the Dora's screen time.
Last year Vanity Fair reported that in an
early rough cut of footage from the film,
there was a scene of the Dora Milaje dancing
on a boat which featured "[Danai] Gurira's
Okoye and [Florence] Kasumba's Ayo swaying
rhythmically back in formation with the rest
of their team.
Okoye eyes Ayo flirtatiously for a long time
as the camera pans in on them.
Eventually, she says, appreciatively and appraisingly,
'You look good.'
Ayo responds in kind [and] Okoye grins and
replies, 'I know.'"
While some of the dancing did make it into
the final film, the flirtation between Okoye
and Ayo, who in the comics has a romantic
relationship with another Dora Milaje, was
cut.
In an interview with Vulture, Ayo actress
Kasumba seemed to confirm the moment had been
filmed but that it was given the chop.
While Kasumba couldn't confirm the reason
for its removal, she suggested it might have
been because the movie had a lot to do in
introducing the world of Wakanda and needed
to keep the focus on T'Challa.
However, this isn't the first time that a
scene which hints towards an LGBTQ character
has been cut from a Marvel movie, the most
recent being in Thor: Ragnarok where a scene
of a woman leaving Valkyrie's bedroom was
deleted from that film.
In the MCU's Black Panther, Okoye is in a
relationship with W'Kabi and that ends up
being significant in the movie's finale; so,
I wonder whether that played any part in the
decision to drop the earlier moment between
Okoye and Ayo.
An interview with the film's co-writer Joe
Robert Cole indicates that may be the case
as he suggests that they did have the LGBTQ
storyline from the comics in mind though it
wouldn't have been 'a major theme' and they
also discussed many different arcs for different
characters.
Although Kasumba has said that she felt it
was important in this first film to just establish
the Dora Milaje as a unit, she would still
like Ayo's sexuality to be explored in a future
Black Panther movie.
Michael B. Jordan's Killmonger has been rightfully
praised for bringing an excellent antagonist
into the MCU, however, in the early stages,
Ryan Coogler, who's a comics fan himself,
had plans to introduce a different villain
into the movie.
That villain was Kraven the Hunter who first
appeared in The Amazing Spider-Man comics
and is a big-game hunter.
Coogler particularly enjoyed Christopher Priest's
run on the Black Panther comics where Panther
fought Kraven, however, Marvel told him he
couldn't use the character.
I suspect because Kraven was introduced in
the Spider-Man comics, the character is bundled
up with Sony's Spider-Man rights.
Obviously, we do have Spider-Man in the MCU
right now, however, that was a specific arrangement
which Marvel Studios had to broker with Sony.
Sony themselves are developing their own Spider-Man-related
universe, which appears to be separate to
the MCU, with characters like Venom, Silver
Sable and Black Cat, and possibly even Kraven
himself.
When Ryan Coogler and Joe Robert Cole started
working on ideas for the movie, another character
they seriously thought about including was
Patriot, aka Elijah Bradley, who's one of
the founders of the Young Avengers.
In the comics, Patriot is the grandson of
Isaiah Bradley, who was one of 300 African-Americans
soldiers used as test subjects for the Super
Soldier Serum [that created Captain America].
The thing is though, Patriot isn't actually
part of Black Panther's story in the comics,
and that's why Coogler ultimately decided
against introducing him in the movie, as he
wanted to concentrate more on Wakanda and
characters who were already part of that world.
Showing us the nation of Wakanda in all its
glorious detail was always going to be a central
part of the Black Panther movie, but so was
travelling beyond the African country's borders
as the filmmakers wanted to give a sense of
some of the effects of Wakanda's isolationism.
But while the finished film globe-trots between
Busan, South Korea; Oakland, California; London;
Vienna; and Nigeria's Sambisa Forest, an early
draft of the movie also included a sequence
in Chicago.
According to screenwriter Joe Robert Cole,
it was going to be a 'pretty big' scene, though
sadly he didn't elaborate.
One of the standouts in Black Panther was
Letitia Wright's Shuri, tech genius and T'Challa's
little sister.
Shuri is also an interesting character in
the comics who's taken on the mantle of Black
Panther herself on occasions [when T'Challa
has been unavailable].
And, in fact, Letitia Wright has said she
thought Ryan Coogler had toyed with the idea
of setting up Shuri as a Black Panther and
I can see a hint to that in the neckpiece
with panther teeth that she wore in some scenes
of the movie.
For the moment, I expect T'Challa will be
the only Black Panther, and Shuri's appearances
in Avengers: Infinity War and other crossovers
will again showcase her incredible tech skills
and ability to create highly advanced gadgets.
But perhaps when Black Panther's sequel arrives
in Phase 4, we could see Shuri put on a Black
Panther suit.
She could either be an additional Black Panther
to T'Challa or she could take over from him,
for example, if he were injured.
After all there were three suits in her lab.
T'Challa took one, of course, and I think
Killmonger took the gold-necklaced suit, which
would conveniently leave one spare for Shuri.
And that's without even counting any future
suits she might design.
Now, what do you think about any of the deleted
scenes or things which didn't make it into
Black Panther?
Is there anything you wish had been included
or are you happy with the final version?
Let me know your thoughts in the comments
below and don't forget to also subscribe to
enter my Black Panther giveaway!
If you enjoyed this, do hit the like button
and share the video.
And why not join the notification squad by
clicking the bell for all my new videos?!
Also tap any of the links here to check out
more videos you might like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!